les autres joueurs sont morts
mais on les a battus à leur propre jeu
j'ai trouvé d'autres vainqueurs et ils
vont nous aider à abattre mis 9 jeux
vient
mino se cache dans le centre de
manhattan
bienvenue dans les escales promis non
non non
[Musique]
grâce bruit
minos savait qu'on venait chance on
connaît tous la règle du jeu soit on
joue fois on a toutes les mauvaises
publicités doit être descendu sur ce
live en tuant étirer les poignets qui
correspond de l'ecti m'en tape rapp est
ouverte on a réussi
on est toujours dans le jeu
on peut pas gagner il savait absolument
tout sur nous les dommages c'était des
coordonnées 12h07 droit s'ajoute un
battre aux yeux ni maintenant ni jamais
[Musique]